that was definitely rock bottom for me
Gisele Bundchen getting real about her
tumultuous 20s when she appeared on Good
Morning America to promote her new book
lessons my path to a meaningful life
mm-hmm holding back tears the supermodel
details experiencing her first panic
attack that eventually led her to
contemplate suicide it started all in a
little plane he kind of started this
kind of fear of being in small spaces so
he started with a little plane ride but
then it became like tunnels subways
elevators my world just kept getting
smaller and smaller that was sorry it
was like I was trapped and I you know I
couldn't breathe it even outside of my
own balcony from that moment on I
realized that my life needed to change
since that pivotal moment Giselle has
turned her life around for the better as
an author mother and wife to New England
Patriots quarterback Tom Brady I've
always wanted to have a family and that
was you know when I became a mother it
really became my priority and to be
there for my husband too you know
because for him to have the space to
live what he loves so much and I was
actually living what I love so much
which is being a mom and a nurturer and
taking care of my family was just very
it was just very different than what I
was used to so it took some time to
adjust gizelle says she made a complete
lifestyle change taking up yoga giving
up cigarettes and trading in wine and
coffee for a clean diet
it's a plant-based diet she and her
family live by I think she's very
disciplined you know with what she eats
as for her relationship with husband Tom
she explains why she's overprotective
and once expressed her desire for him to
retire soon
I never seen someone love something as
much as he loves football and it makes
me happy if I said anything in the past
is because you have a concern
you just feel very protective of them so
obviously if someone hurts my children
my husband anyone I love I get like a
lioness
[Music]
[Applause]